opening it's still early days but
it's the theme of today the isolated
queens pawn the itp again so this time
it's black with an isolated queen's pawn
in the center there
so long term white is doing great but
black will get some dynamic play as
compensation for his weak pawn so
white's castled black dark squared
bishop is now going to come out
and uh yeah still very well known
territory this position could actually
transpose to a karakan defense with
colours reversed you can transpose to a
nimbo indian defense with colours
reversed this type of general pattern
this outline can arise from so diff so
many different openings as we've seen
throughout today actually this
isolated queen's pawn position so yeah
strap ourselves in it's going to be
i think very very tense as vincent tries
to go for the win black bishop now just
coming out and creating a pin another
theme of today lots of pins yeah i like
it when we have these themes for a
beginner like myself makes it a little
bit easier to uh to learn and to
recognize these patterns
so the thank you to the players is it a
coincidence you think or or is it like
themes in world chats
that they will be following yeah often
patterns happen openings go in and out
of fashion
um often very playable openings just get
forgotten for years um and often as well
uh isolated queens pawns
those have gone through trends for many
many years people avoided them at the
top level now they seem to love them
especially from the black side
um so yeah the players adhering to these
kind of thematic
pawn structures these thematic ideas
just using that pattern recognition to
get by
definitely
well vincent keimer 15 minutes on the
clock they have played fast in the
opening here rihanna pogba she's played
very fast has that actually been a trend
for jan in the tournament so far played
very very fast very very fast i mean
he's been very confident i mean this
obviously has its advantages and
disadvantages because it has meant that
he has squandered away great
opportunities so i mean just thinking
back the first game against chemo he had
a fantastic position because he took
some quick decisions
he uh ruined it and the game ended in a
draw yeah um here this this opening
seems to be very much instill in the
realms of what has been played before
and uh this is all following the main
line and now white's idea in this
position is actually to drop the light
squared bishop back to break this
unpleasant pin that black has against
the knight and the queen
yeah maybe we can show this because pin
pins have been a theme for today and
this pin is extremely annoying for white
not just now but also long term if white
for example wants to
bring the white queen out at any point
then the black bishop will take this
knight and ruin white's pawn structure
so as you vanco mentioned dropping this
bishop back at some point either now or
in the next couple of turns will surely
happen at least now white's knight can
move safely without the queen behind it
being attacked white's queen can also
move safely without any compromise uh
compromising pawn structure arising uh
we should also mention there is also a
trap in the position some viewers at
home might be wondering why white can't
just get greedy and grab this pawn in
the middle of the board but after knight
takes pawn we would see a trade and
after white's queen recaptures where she
saw this theme arise earlier there's a
loose piece in the position the white
queen undefended and that means the
bishop can jump out the way with a check
gaining time and now the white queen
would also fall off the board and ivanka
called it this bishop maneuver has
happened not quite in this position uh
white dodging the trap of knight takes
pawn white pushed a pawn first black
castled and now the bishop has dropped
back and this pin has been broken this
is a good pattern to remember at home
break the pins because they will annoy
you
eternally if you don't
meanwhile white wants to develop the
bishop on the long diagonal if possible
all right
essipanko eric hansen game three i
actually think the bar is slightly over
to the canadian side in that one they
are tied still after two games uh
definitely there will be a game for
between those two but a win with black
pieces there wow that would be huge for
eric hansen and look at that ding the
bar has just shot up for the chinese in
game three against artemium and if he
does win that he will be ready for the
semi-final to face
probably magnus carlsen or liam lee if
leila is able to make a comeback
and okay we had at least one move yeah
and black's actually played a very
instructive maneuver and a very common
maneuver we've talked about themes that
arise in this type of pawn structure
black's bishop is dropped back and look
at the square that the bishop has just
come from the d6 square black's queen is
now actually just going to drop down two
squares and
she's going to team up with her dark
square bishop and try to go towards the
white king this uh this theme arose
earlier in the tournament earlier in the
air things masters between magnus
carlsen and alexandra castenik magnus
beat kustanyak using this exact idea
bringing the black queen onto the same
diagonal as the dark squared bishop and
going for checkmate so a bit scary for
vincent to deal with there are ideas to
blunt this uh this pattern actually i
know peter lecco his coach
with colors reversed played a very
thematic idea in this position moving
the white knight out the way the white
kingside knight putting it actually on
the edge of the board but i'm just
wondering whether vincent is familiar
with those types of ideas because in
that game that peter lecko instructively
won very quickly uh it was colors
reversed from a different opening
so that's the move i expect to see but
vincent how familiar is he with the
ideas here jan clearly still in his
preparation look at the clock times wow
already a gap opening up so so lekko
that we're talking about that is uh
the coach for vincent carmer yeah but is
he the coach for yana pognati as well or
is he the second he's the second
a little bit different roles you know uh
peter lecko is like everything to
vincent gamer he's like the coach mentor
and uh probably
you know from my understanding is
probably delivers chess files early in
the morning and maybe vincent goes yes i
like this i like this i'll play it um
with uh his work with napomiasi is
probably
along with the same lines but more like
delivering the lines and then they kind
of spar a little bit and they discuss
that but of course as a second he's not
the only one you know it's he's part of
a team and for sure there will be like
non-disclosure agreements and all sorts
of things so it's a big real conflict of
interest here for peter lecko yeah he
cannot help either of the players no
right morally right
plus he's commentating on the gm stream
yeah so he has to suffer in public yeah
definitely and uh
obviously comment on the moves david but
i also want to ask do you who else was
working with jan for the world
championship match
he never actually revealed all of the
names from his team we know vladimir
potkin he was the most visible um second
of yanaponyishis he's been working with
him for years there was ilda herrulin
another russian grandmaster who's from
the 1990 generation they've known each
other for
what is it 20 plus years and uh he was
another main guy we know maybe sergey
king was playing training games with jan
rumors about rajabov i think tomaszewski
was another rumor many many of the top
russian grandmasters but by the way jan
had a whole army behind him vincent only
really has peter lecker
which is good enough yeah but uh yeah
for peter it's
an awkward situation meanwhile talking
of awkward situations look at vincent
still thinking whereas jan playing
instantly on every single move and
there's a pawn sacrifice in the air but
i don't think white should get greedy in
this position
let's jump in simon what do you think is
bishop takes pawn gonna get punished in
this position um but if you can take the
pawn i think you should you know because
you've got to win this game you've got
to take some risks so um can he get away
with it i mean it looks dangerous for
the white king but
what does black actually do against this
move
yeah so after bishop takes pawn i mean a
few things come to mind for example at
the very minimum black can just move the
rook across i just have a feeling white
is a bit stuck
and in this position black has ideas
such as bringing the knight to the side
capturing this pawn it's all about this
diagonal the queen and bishop if they
can break through and get to the white
king it's just going to be checkmate and
i don't see any real moves for white
you've got to be really careful here and
uh actually i'm pretty i mean i'm trying
to wrap my brains but i'm pretty sure
i've studied this position or at least
very similar to this position before and
in this position i remember the white
knight jumping in to be a key move or at
least uh this
idea either now or the next few turns
because you break the connection with
black's queen and rook to the knight in
the center of the board and this knight
is protected by the bishop so if black
takes it then you can jump forward with
the queen and now you are the one lining
up towards the black king and i think
this would maybe have given white a
small advantage if i remember correctly
but similar stuff has happened in the
game uh white didn't get greedy and
grabbed this pawn which might have been
a bit too slow it would have lost a lot
of time instead dropping back with his
knight and after a trade we see black's
rook sliding across and
white has the advantage of the two
bishops long term these bishops are
great on these two diagonals a bit of
x-ray vision there but uh
black is so active black has every piece
in the game look how centralized these
four black well these five black pieces
are
and uh white has to deal with their
activity meanwhile white lining up
against this pawn
i still like what vincent's doing to be
honest
it looks good two bishops i mean there's
no weaknesses in in white's position and
if white can also bring his rooks to the
center of the board and just get rid of
the powerful blackrooks and he's going
to have the long-term advantage and i
think you mentioned earlier david if you
think about exchanges if all the heavy
pieces come off the board so we talk
about the queens and the rooks you can
just imagine them being removed then
white would have a very very nice
advantage there um in an open position
with the two bishops so
i like the way the move jans played
yan's a very active player and he's now
gone to at least activate his knight and
he's creating some threats here himself
jumping in uh with a potential fork in
the position and again active defense is
the best way to play so that night move
is is is certainly going to ask some
questions though yeah and uh i think
this is the style that he very much
needs to adopt
adopt from now on because like you
mentioned
white has all the trumps take them
two bishops open position
you know just perfect i mean the knight
doesn't have a post the black knight
doesn't have a post
uh i really don't like jan's position
but having said that there's a concrete
threat knight jumping into d2 square as
david highlighted and how to react to
that i'm not sure it's a threat though
to be honest in the position uh because
if the knight does jump in white's queen
can actually swing across team up with
her dark square bishop and threaten
checkmate um so maybe actually that
would be a mistake for black's knight to
jump in i think the more pressing uh
concern for white is black's bishop just
sliding to the b6 square onto the same
diagonal as the white king and creating
some pressure that way
and uh meanwhile vincent
he's playing been playing a bit slowly
in this game maybe due to his co2 levels
the air quality
not great
uh from where he's playing right now
instead he does slide his rook across so
now the night jump by black would be a
mistake but queen would just swing
across
and uh i like the way he's playing this
so i mean he's getting some chances and
that's all all you can do at this level
get some chances get a position that you
can play uh keep your keep the the match
alive here uh if he can swap some rooks
off which he's uh trying to do
with that last move then he wants to get
these bishops really working in the
ending um
so i don't know i think there's some
chances here definitely definitely if
jan isn't accurate over the next three
or four moves we could end up in that
situation you mentioned simon earlier
with all the pieces coming off brooks
queens
and just eternal torture yeah black with
those two bishops yeah uh being far
superior to the black knight okay wow
yan bringing his queen this way
uh just i guess still defending his
knight from the side but after a rook
trade
white is slightly closer to that goal
yeah of uh eliminating all the pieces
who do you think peter lecko is is
cheering for secretly here i mean
because
you know he's got his his star pupil uh
and obviously he's got the you know the
guy he's been teaching for the world
championships i mean
oh that's a tough one i don't think we
can even answer that can we can we
answer that one
i think we we can hazard a guess okay
who are your anchors you want to go
first i'll go first i reckon he's going
for the youngster me too i reckon he's
like yeah come on i'm going to be
teaching this because he's being like
the mentor and of and uh okay so he's
he's like part of a team with me but
then again think about what it must mean
for jan after
you know a tough time during the world
championship match to just
show that he's back at the top and maybe
to even play the finals here with uh
magnus yeah yeah i mean maybe the ideal
world is that peter wants it to go to a
tie break and just let it happen there
yeah
and also we want to see the extra
excitement right so yeah
i think there's a good chance here i
think there's a good chance that white
could uh keep doing what he's doing he's
pushing black back a little bit he's
making progress slowly but surely here
um i don't know if he can go for the
exchanges of brooks now that's something
well he can't exchange both pairs off
because there is a weakness a lot of
weaknesses around the white king here
is there a immediate threat here bishop
takes pawn um potentially so there's
still danger for white but he's just got
to be careful got to be careful on this
diagonal in particular so if white is
careless and
trying to find a move for example just
pushing pushing the pawn forward then we
might see a rook trade
bishop takes pawn now this point is
pinned another theme of the day and due
to this pin the bishop cannot be
recaptured and actually black is just
going to crash through on this square
with the bishop knight and queen from
afar and that means that white most
likely has to do something quickly
i would just flick in this exchange just
because it i don't see what else to do
yet uh rook takes rook black's bishop
has to recapture the rook is required to
defend this knight so black's bishop has
to step back and take the rook
and now is the moment to look for
something for white the problem is if
the rook slides across trying to create
a pin then i guess the knight will just
be backed up by a pawn
and it does look like like it's very
weakening for the black king but then
again white's a bit stuck this queen is
required defending the pawn behind it
and it's not 100 easy for white to get
organized meanwhile black is going to
try and put pressure on this square over
the next few turns or maybe even offer a
trade of one of the bishops when he
would breathe a sigh of relief once the
bishop disappears
life is never simple right thank you we
were like yeah yeah you know what has an
advantage and then david shows us
otherwise like oh okay i mean i'm pretty
sure white has the advantage i don't
think it's ever worse but yeah not so
easy to play easy
and well it's going to build up to the
excitement and whilst we're waiting for
the players to make a decision i have a
few selfies oh yeah because i love it
when people share their selfies from all
around the world and uh first up is
skywalker who gives us a shout out from
italy
good beautiful chess and two slices of
pizza
nice oh i want to see that pizza i want
to see that pizza two favorite food is
pizza and pasta i don't want to see it
otherwise i'll get hungry
oh how do you get oh you guys are lucky
wait what is hello in it i was going to
say bonjour but that's french that's
french
why can i come up with hello in italian
hold on a minute i just got ciao but
that's goodbye yeah um
lazy in england aren't we i mean
learning languages i mean
we're quite lucky that everyone learns
english really because yeah
do you
speak a bit norwegian do you know i
speak a bit of norwegian and i have a
great talent that i've made norwegian
sound like it's english
norwegian is very good
english
well it's like norwegians being very
able to make english sound norwegian as
well
all right well uh thank you for sending
in selfies that looks very nice
and uh who can celebrate with the pizza
among these two today
jana pogbachie is it getting close for
him or is he in trouble possibly i think
he's just found a very good move as
black we did see one set of rooks leave
the board once that exchanged white's
queen slid across and now look at this
the black knight stepped back attacking
the white queen and we've seen the queen
trade actually and uh everything's just
getting eliminated that is the problem
we mentioned white wants this position
but with the rooks off the board and
this black rook has just got active so
now white's dark squared bishop under
fire on the second rank from that black
rook it has to move
maybe you could defend it with your own
rook but um i'm expecting white's bishop
to move and
if the two pawns on the left side get
eliminated those two arie pawns alice uh
if they're both swapped off
white is just running out of material if
it's just pawns on one side of the board
knights become quite good and they will
the two bishops together will not really
be able to make any headway so it's all
about those two remaining pawns on the a
file right now if they stay on the board
vincent as white has great winning
chances if they are traded it's going to
be a draw
the bar has shot up in game three
between ezepenko and hansen looking good
for andreas penko with the white pieces
in that game they are tied after two
games a win here will be a huge for
essipanko that means eric hansen will
have to win
game four to take that one to tie breaks
and the bar also all the way over to
ding side if that is a win it will be
over he will be ready for the semifinals
in game four just started between liam
le and magnus carlsen liam he has to win
that game to take it to tie breaks
wow and i just took a peek over magnus
carlsen just needs to draw as black but
he's sacrificed to pawn and gone for a
crazy variation actually one that i've
seen you play simon oh wow so
that's a that's worrying
so uh he's following the simon williams
ginger gm school of chess getting
worried for magnus if he's doing that
though
but is that telling us that magnus is
back in form basically it shows he's
feeling more confident at least
we'll still see whether he's able to
avoid the blunders we saw in the prelims
but magnus uh yeah brave opening choice
i like it yeah i think he's played this
before as well this line uh i think he
played did he play against um sam
shanklin i think uh recently so it's uh
yeah and i think it's one of those lines
which they they've calculated so deeply
that it's supposed to be equal you know
just computer uh calculations so i think
it's quite a quite a sort of safe uh
sacrifice that magnus is playing their
activity uh and it does look in the
current game at the moment i really like
the way jan's done this he's kept active
he kept he's making threats with his
pieces and that's uh keeping the balance
here and not allowing uh vincent to to
consolidate uh well the advantage of the
bishops uh probably looking like a draw
and the time situation okay still uh
still quite safe for both sides
yeah very safe in the formula she has
only seconds
less than what he started with vincent
was shaking his head as well a moment
ago look at vincent he's not happy and
he would love to just wave a magic wand
and get the rooks off the board but
black is just too active yeah could i
just ask you guys to peek at the game
three ding artemyev because i see the
bar has just
gone the complete opposite way saying a
win for our tamiya now
yeah it looks like he's lost control
uh
i think ding was just in charge and
maybe just took his eye off the ball for
one move and it's a full 360. it's not
over there's still a lot of life in the
position but ding has missed a few
knockout blows
and uh
maybe given a second life yeah in this
match wow all right interesting
he hasn't been himself as he ding i mean
he's i think it's probably because he's
playing a very funny time zone but he
he's uh he didn't do these things a
couple of years ago you know lillian
advantages slip like that so
um i think we just saw a result as well
essepenko has just beaten eric in that
game oh wow jeez that's eric yeah that
means eric hansen he must win game four
to take that one to tie breaks he will
have the white pieces in game four uh
that's going to be interesting to follow
if it is a draw or a win for ezypanko
then he will be ready for semi-finals
where he will face the winner of this
quarterfinal match
right now looking like it will be on the
publicity who is up by one point but i
understand on you guys definitely
winning chances for vincent in this game
yeah if he can somehow activate the
white rook or swap off the rooks then i
think he's going to be the favorite but
there's some threats in the position
actually and uh let's just show why
white can't grab a pawn in the current
position um
if we jump in we can see that white is
attacking this guy i mentioned it was
all about these two pawns uh white's
pawn surviving in order to create
winning chances later and pushing up the
board and trying to get rid of black's
pawn in the process but if you grab this
pawn now
then the black knight will jump in and
it's a double attack actually attacking
the white rook and if the white rook
moves this is a nasty fork hidden the
white king hitting the white bishop and
it's just game over black would win that
is why white had to take a time out and
instead of grabbing this pawn had to
step back with his bishop but now black
is able to save this pawn and still
threats persist of ideas like the knight
jumping in black can even at some point
to start going after white's pawn
with his rook or with his bishop
it's looking like this rook is just
dominating white's army right now
especially white's rook just not
participating do you think napoleon has
chances to win
because uh it looks quite scary right
with the
the a pawn advancing
yeah i mean i don't think he needs to
win so if there's any way he can you
know wait doesn't need to win but if
there's any way he can liquidate the
position then he will i would imagine
like maybe with a knight d2 move trying
to swap off and get to again another
theme maybe he can play that now um
potentially get to opposite kind of
bishop position and take the draw but
okay you're right though if he wins that
airport is
vincent is
panicking a little bit yeah i think so
because now if one pair of bishops get
exchanged which they can do all of a
sudden white's king side is is very weak
and you might even lose the pawn on the
side yeah this is okay there is
something there is some chance yeah hope
that you hit this uh f7 pawn might
bishop on a great diagonal but even if
black was a drop back here i don't see
any real danger um the black rook going
passive just defending this pawn and
then the knight can drop back and i
think black would be completely fine but
nepo finds maybe even even better way
just brings his bishop one square across
so bishop trade still allowed but now if
they come off then white's rook isn't
active on this line at least so
yeah this game
fully under control from the pontiac he
doesn't need to win but it does look
like if anyone his position is easier to
play so in the current position black
buying up this pawn
hoping for a bishop trade and if the
bishops disappear no more bishop pair
the game will be a draw and artemis he
has won game three against sting ooh
this quarter final day is uh
definitely heating up
game for now they will be tied heading
into that if we have a winner in that
game then that player will be the winner
of that quarter final if it is a draw
then those two will head into uh tie
breaks all right
yeah i'll tell you it's so tricky yeah
you saw on last season's tour even in
terrible positions he always finds
resources
and i have to say ding might be feeling
a little sense of deja vu oh yeah
because i do remember in the 2021 gold
gold money asian rapid
he won the first day of uh knockouts and
the second day
he could have finished it off actually
but he didn't and he allowed artemis to
strike back and of course when it came
to tie break artemis was dominant yeah
so
yeah these kind of things chess players
don't forget
and if it goes to tie breaks i think
artemiev will be a big favorite not just
because he's a blitz specialist but also
because it's going to be 5 am in the
morning for ding imagine playing blitz
chess to survive in a tournament maybe
even armageddon chess at 5 00 a.m after
you've been playing throughout the
entire night that's insane oh easy yeah
and our time also will have momentum
going into game four after a win okay
bunch of moves yeah a bunch of moves and
look at that the pawns have disappeared
also a bishop for nitrate there's just
not sufficient material left this game
is just dead drawn at the moment yeah
and that means jan will be ready for uh
semi-finals solid day from him today i
feel and uh i was wondering if you're
gonna pick one of the younger players in
this competition to
become world champion so something you
know put you on the spot which who would
you pick well one of them already was
world champion
naughty back right okay of course yeah
yeah yeah yeah naughty between had a
fantastic rapid result uh i suppose i
mean like world champion of the world i
mean
would you who would you go for because
they've all got a chance haven't they i
mean after prague's brilliant result
against uh you know carlson you might go
for him but then uh you've got espnko
you've got loads of great players and
yeah i don't know who i'd pick probably
prague i'd go for prague probably you'd
like to pick one but we're heading for a
draw here and uh yeah that could be yan
versus magnus on the way in the final as
well
they're on collision course for each
other right um jan and magnus and the
reason we say this is a dead draw is
because if you look at the pawns they're
all on one side of the board the fact
that black has double pawns doesn't
really affect anything white doesn't
have the pieces to attack double pawns
you often need knights to attack those
so yeah it's just three pawns versus
three pawns on the same side no way to
sneak past and create a pass pawn
and uh the rooks balance each other out
the bishops balance each other out and
that is why it's just a draw nothing to
be done jan's just gonna wait with his
rook and white has no plan
to break through
so we'll see a few more moves i think
vincent just coming to terms with the
fact his tournament's going to be over
just enjoying every single moment of
this experience
and uh yeah would you say it's a
breakthrough for him or is that
overdoing it i mean has he always
already made his big breakthrough in top
top of chess he's made some breakthrough
um i mean even when i think he was 12 13
years old he won this grand a tournament
one of the biggest opens in the world
um and recently he qualified for the
grand prix he's been doing great lately
but
he'll get more belief now i think this
is the first time he's really been
beating some of the top players
i know it's just rapid chess but
for these young players it is all about
that yeah kind of confidence and belief
that they can compete and he knows he
can now it's been so close in this match
today as well
super impressive by vincent keimer but
it probably stops here janupomnyachi is
up by one point this is game four he
only needs a joy in that game this game
and it looks like that's gonna happen
any second house still with how many how
much time eighteen yeah up to 16 minutes
sixteen and seven
i need to get some glasses yes i mean
that's still a lot of time yeah more
time than he started with which is like
yeah he's made it look easy so uh i mean
i was talking about confidence for the
young players but look at these guys
nepalniachi and ronia and they all play
instantly these days yeah trusting their
instincts that's another key thing in
chess yeah we've seen this position
before yeah just going around in circles
now just playing it out so
well how impressed are you guys bayana
pognyacci in this tournament he seems
almost invincible yeah and he seems calm
that's the main thing yeah in the world
championship match we commentated on he
was never really calm in the second half
at least
but he's got that kindness back and
that's the key yeah yeah i think it's a
confidence thing isn't it i mean it
happens all the time chess is a is a
mind sport game and you've got to you've
got okay is that a draw that is a draw
okay that is the draw and jana pognati
is the first player that is ready for
air things monsters semi-finals